This week, we will examine
some more advanced topics
in the application of
Newton's laws of motion.
First, we will look at more
examples of constrained motion,
where the motion
is forced to obey
some particular
condition in addition
to Newton's laws of motion.
These conditions usually specify
some particular relationship
between coordinates of objects
and the system we are studying.
Specifically, we will
re-examine the case
of objects suspended
with pulleys and ropes,
but with more complex
systems than we
have discussed previously.
The fact that the
ropes have fixed length
will provide a
constraint condition
relating the coordinates
of our various masses.
Second, we will examine
the case of forces
acting on a continuous, extended
mass distribution as opposed
to acting on discrete
point masses.
This will allow us to introduce
a powerful differential
analysis technique from calculus
where we model continuous mass
distributions as made up of
lots of small, discrete mass
elements and then
examine the limiting case
of infinitesimally
small elements
to obtain the
continuous behavior.
This is a technique
that you will
see applied over and over again
in physics and engineering.
And in fact, we will return to
it again later in this course.
Our specific example will
be to study how tension
varies in a long, massive rope.
This is in contrast
to the light,
effectively massless ropes
that we discussed previously.
Finally, we will discuss
velocity-dependent forces--
that is, forces whose strength
depends on the velocity
or some function of the velocity
of the mass being acted on.
The most common example of this
is resistive forces or drag
forces, which are caused
by motion of a solid object
through a fluid,
like air or water.
That is the example we
will discuss this week.
Another example
you may be aware of
is the magnetic force that acts
on a charged particle, which
depends upon the velocity
of the charged particle.
In all three of these
cases, we will simply
be applying Newton's
three laws of motion,
but the situations will require
a more sophisticated treatment
to what has come before.